thank you very much it's a great honor
to be here
and also a relief that I finally made it
to a sea far intense pite of the weather
those some of you may know the story
behind another attempt to visit what I
am going to do to introduce the topic is
to start with a bit of history and also
which will get you tell you a little bit
about why I'm involved in all of this
and so if we could go most of you know
I'm sure all of you know about the
gradients of health across
socio-economic status from the Whitehall
studies of Michael Marmot and colleagues
and work by others in fact I became part
of the MacArthur socioeconomic status
and Health Research Network and that was
really the origins of what I have a lot
of what I have to tell you about today
and certainly my interest in this there
are of course many causes contributions
to these gradients which affect both
mortality and morbidity and our my
interest is of course the biological
side and how that interacts with the
this the social environment and other
aspects of a person's a person's life
now the MacArthur Network which included
Michael Marmot and and others Nancy
Adler was our chair produced a document
which is for public consumption led to
an academic treatise which has some
wonderful articles and was a stimulus
for a video which has been widely used
on this the topic of disparities and
health and of course the Acheson report
which in the UK which grew out of an
interest in from the Whitehall studies
advocated that all
public policies are really health
policies and need to be thought of in
that way and this is something that
societies are trying to emulate those of
us who are aware of this are trying to
get our governments and private
enterprise to do this but one of the
elements that came out of this certainly
in my awareness was the importance of
early life and and so what I'm going to
tell you is sort of a top-down fashion
are things that involve how of course
how important the brain is and this is a
figure you will see many times focusing
on stressors on the genetic gene
environment interactions and then the
central notion is that the brain is the
central organ because it perceives what
is potentially threatening what is
stressful produces behavioral and
physiological responses so let's sort of
take this apart so stressors in life
stressors include of course trauma and
abuse major life events the
environmental influences the very common
influences that we experience every day
and our families our neighborhoods our
social environments our working
environments and they produce effects
and one way of talking about stressors
is to think about something using the
word which can be very ambiguous
positive stress so you feel exhilarated
from doing something that has a
satisfying outcome like giving a talk
writing a paper that was successful and
in order to do that you have to go have
a good sense of yourself a good sense of
self esteem ability to that you're in
control of what's going on then there's
tolerable stress where of course
something happens major life events a
but you're well prepared because of the
your ability to control things and you
have good social and emotional support
that material support and you're able to
weather the storm and then there's
something which is
toxic stress which almost speaks for
itself where one doesn't perhaps have
those attributes the neural unhealthy
one has unhealthy brain architecture
we'll talk about what that may mean and
poor social and emotional support and
this then may be exacerbated by early
life or or throughout life experience of
chaos abuse neglect and so forth
so we'll talk about these things but
then we get back to we come to the
physiologic responses and this concept
which we helped to introduce aloe stasis
is a word that means the active process
of putting out mediators that lead to
adaptation and and survival a idea that
was put forth by Peter Stirling and
Joseph ire for the cardiovascular system
and something that we generalized with
the help of the late Eliot stellar and
an earlier MacArthur Network to pertain
to all mediators of stress and
adaptation and the concept then is that
when these systems are overused and by a
lot of stress or dysregulated internally
with respect to each other and I'll tell
you what that means in a minute this
leads to something we call a low static
load now when we think about stress we
often think about cortisol and the fact
that cortisol is is produced in response
to ACTH coming from the pituitary gland
and that ACTH is stimulated by releasing
factors from the hypothalamus which are
in turn caused to be released by by
neural inputs from both physical and
psychological stressors what is not
perhaps fully appreciated is that the
acute actions of cortisol and for that
matter adrenaline the other stress
hormone actually enhance functions such
as immunity actually enhances adaptive
immunity promotes certain aspects of
memory promotes energy replenishment and
more of
and cardiovascular function and of
course we're probably only too well
aware mmm because cortisol is usually
talked about in a negative sense that it
can suppress immune function that may be
useful in the case of an inflammation or
an autoimmune disease but it can impair
immunity impaired memory and chronically
secreted promote bone mineral loss
muscle wasting and contribute to the
metabolic syndrome so we talked about
inverted use now cortisol and adrenaline
are not the only mediators related to
space and adaptation we have the both
the pro and anti-inflammatory components
of the so called immune system and and
the widespread nature of these
inflammatory and Pro and anti
inflammatory chemicals in the body we
have not only cortisol and sympathetic
activity we also have parasympathetic
activity we have oxidative stress a
little bit of which is needed for cells
to function normally
we have the DHEA and androgen from the
adrenals and the arrows indicate that
all of these are interacting with each
other affecting each other's production
they are affecting all systems of the
body including the brain simultaneously
and their interactions can be described
as each of them as was the case where
cortisol has biphasic and nonlinear and
moreover there are of course not only
unhealthy lifestyle we'll talk about in
a minute poor sleep but toxic chemicals
in the in my environment feed into this
network and for example elevate
inflammatory tone which in turn can lead
to elevated cortisol so this is what
we're talking about complicated but this
is really what is going on within our
bodies and it's not all bad it's not all
good and it's the balance that is the
key and one of these factors that
involves the balance is is our
behavioral response
to stressors whether they are positive
and health-promoting or maladaptive and
health damaging and a way to think about
this is to think about this term
stressed out which I think we all
experienced from time to time feeling
overwhelmed out of control exhausted
frustrated anxious angry even and what
happens to us we lose sleep at night we
may eat too many of the wrong things too
much alcohol drinking too much alcohol
smoking if we're so inclined and of
course neglecting what we know should be
regular patterns of physical activity
exercise because we're in front of our
computers doing things that were sitting
not moving all of these contribute to a
low static loads so psychosocial stress
is of course a major factor contributing
to this condition and then we have we
come to the brain and this is the
subject of our research in the
laboratory and and I want to tell you
just a little bit about that one of the
things we've learned over the last
several decades is that the brain and
the adult brain as well as the
developing brain is a lot more plastic
and malleable than we ever thought it
would be that the dendrites of nerve
cells is of course where the cell
nucleus where the genetic information
resides the dendritic some any cells can
expand or contract with experience
aided by hormones in some cases that
synapses on these dendrites the sites of
input from other nerve cells are
remodeled steadily at least a subset of
them are continually being formed and
replaced they have a life a maturation
of the of their own and surprisingly
there is a limited amount of
neurogenesis the generation of new nerve
cells in especially in the brain region
called the hippocampus which continues
in some brain areas
and elderly people can be reactivated
are enhanced by such things as regular
exercise we talk about three areas of
the brain the hippocampus where we a
long time ago discovered the receptors
for adrenal steroids for cortisol which
is important for memory and mood
regulation but also it helps shut off a
stress stress response we have the
amygdala located down here which is
important for anxiety fear and
aggression turns on it turns on stress
hormones and increases heart rate for
example and in its physiologic role and
the frontal prefrontal cortex which is
important for all manner of
self-regulatory behaviors emotional
regulation working memory and it also
physiologically helps to shut off the
stress response so if the architecture
of these brain areas is remodeled in
some fashion the balance between these
brain areas will change and if for
example the amygdala becomes overactive
this may be a good adaptation to a
dangerous situation because one is more
vigilant but if this stops if the danger
passes and the amygdala is still more
active than this is an anxiety disorder
a depressive disorder so one as I said
we discovered that these receptors for
cortisol in the major cell layers of the
hippocampus the receptors for these four
stress hormones end up in the cell
nucleus and regulate gene expression and
one of the things that happens we
discovered when an animal is chronically
stressed is that there is a release of
the neurotransmitter glutamate which is
part of normal synaptic transmission but
it happens during stress somebody showed
that if you would drain electa mize
animals they do not show this increase
in glutamate and what happens if you
chronically stress an animal is that the
apical dendrites of these nerve cells in
this part of the
the campus called the ca3 become shorter
and less branched because of the
activity of overactivity of both
cortisol and glutamate and we can block
these with certain antidepressants with
benzodiazepines it's an active process
involving both the circulating hormone
and the endogenous neurotransmitter and
it's largely reversible in a young
animal with a healthy brain so this is
not brain damage
now there's neurogenesis in this part of
the hippocampus the dentate gyrus that
continues and can be suppressed by
chronic stress the same kind of chronic
stress that causes these dendrites to
shrink you have to do that a bit longer
you actually get the entire hippocampus
to shrink and become smaller other
people have shown that regular activity
physical activity actually causes more
neurogenesis and in enlarges they have
to campus and we'll come to that in a
moment
then I'm getting back to something that
goes back to the early stages of my cage
D training the idea that that there are
these epigenetic regulations that
histones which are basic proteins that
cause folding it on or unfolding of the
DNA so that it can be read or repressed
that these modifications occur as a
result of acute and chronic stress and
something that we're currently studying
involves how the hippocampus and other
brain regions change as a result of
acute and chronic stress and what we
found is that stress activates a core
set of genes but not always in the same
direction depending on the stress
history that chronic stress increases
the gene response overall and including
the response to an acute novel stressor
that recovery from chronic stress alters
the patterns of gene expression to that
same kind of acute novel stressor that
acute stress activates a protective
response to repress potentially disrupt
genetic elements but this response is
diminished with repeated stress and with
aging suggesting some form of
instability and potential for damage and
that individuals differ in their
vulnerability distress as we've seen
this in our animal models and and that
certain gene responses appear to predict
that vulnerability and that epigenetic
factors especially those early in life
but throughout life appear to be
involved so what we're talking about
then are getting back to these inverted
use are these interactions highlighting
both adrenal steroids and excitatory
amino acids but many other players which
acutely enhance activity improve memory
acutely when they are at higher levels
they cause impaired synaptic functioning
but this is a short lasting phenomenon
and then longer lasting we have what we
call adaptive plasticity involving the
remodeling of synapses dendrites and
there are Genesis and then with pro with
extreme trauma as my former colleague
Robert Sapolsky as as very nicely shown
the same players a mediate excitotoxin
II from seizures stroke or head trauma
because they are dysregulated a bit of
sort of allostatic load or we call it
overload but in between you have if you
lose this ability to be resilient in
this adaptive plasticity then you have a
disorder that has to be intervened
treated by some external means such as
an antidepressant or other kinds of
therapy cortisol has turned out not only
to work at the genomic level but it
works in mitochondria to main the energy
supplier of the cell to regulate its
activity it stimulates and inhibits
release
neurotransmitters at the synaptic ending
it directly stimulates release of
glutamate but through the a generation
of endocannabinoids which are the brains
own reason we are respond to marijuana
the brains own endocannabinoids actually
inhibit the release of of glutamate so
they have a kind of a glucocorticoids
can have a stimulatory or inhibitory
function they have checks and balances
and they regulate many different aspects
of cell function over different time
courses in the human brain we know from
translational studies with brain imaging
that hippocampal shrinkage occurs in
major depression and type 2 diabetes in
post-traumatic stress disorder and in
Cushing's disease where it apparently is
at least partially reversible when the
hyper cortisol emia is treated but you
don't have to have a disease with
chronic stress over a long period of
time
chronic jetlag over a shorter period of
time lack of exercise and with the
condition of chronic inflammation there
appears to be hippocampal shrinkage now
the positive side is that regular
exercise as I mentioned enhances
hippocampal function intense learning
does this and antidepressant treatments
also apparently can enlarge the
hippocampus one of the most effective
antidepressants is regular exercise so
let's talk about briefly about other
brain areas while the hippocampus neuron
shrink with repeated stress in this
reversible fashion so do neurons in the
prefrontal cortex which control self
regulatory behaviors working memory but
neurons in the amygdala involved in fear
and anxiety actually expand at the same
time and the animal becomes more anxious
and potentially more aggressive in the
orbital frontal cortex another part of
the prefrontal cortex there's also
expansion of these neurons which
apparently makes the animal
vigilant now this is all well and good
as I said in a dangerous environment
when the danger passes though if this
anxiety continues then that's a problem
an anxiety disorder that has to be
treated so this is the amygdala and one
of the remarkable findings with our
colleague Shona Chatterjee in Bangalore
India is that it with post-traumatic
stress disorder which is thought to
involve something that happens within
the amygdala and other parts of the
brain is that an elevation of cortisol a
timed elevation of cortisol at the time
of trauma or right afterwards can
actually prevent the development of PTSD
so that may be an example of a an over
act and an under activity of cortisol
which contributes to a a major problem
Sonia Luc yen in Montreal has shown that
in children of mothers who are
chronically depressed unfortunately over
a 10-year period that there's
enlargement of the amygdala in those
children along with elevated
glucocorticoids and this is the
chronicity unfortunately of the
depression in the mother so here's an
example one example of the
transgenerational effect of the parental
eternal environment on on the children
again illustrating the importance of
early life events and a potentially very
dangerous consequence of this we also
know that the prefrontal cortex is is
vult is sensitive for example to
circadian disruption and chronic stress
as is the hippocampus and amygdala that
this is reversible and young adults
including human a study on human beings
on medical students studying for their
board exam showing they had impaired
epic antar prefrontal cortical function
but they recovered after a vacation
but there is loss of resilience with
aging we know that we don't know if it
can be
vented and most importantly and I can't
unfortunately talk more about this is
that females respond differently there
are subtle differences in brain
architecture which leads females women
to use different strategies to solve the
same problems as males often doing you
know equally well I mean there's very
little gender differences in this
respect but there are different
strategies that are used because of
these differences in brain architecture
a one very provocative study related to
not just the prefrontal cortex is this
study by Peter Gennaro said Pittsburgh
showing that people with low SES people
are on associate have association with
elevated in inflammation systemic
inflammation and also with differences
in their white matter which of course
was the insulation of the brain and this
is related to you know more schooling as
it seems to be protecting protective and
residing in advantaged neighborhoods so
here we begin to see the impact even at
the level of the brain this is of course
a provocative study that needs to be
studied but it shows the potential
extent to which this health income
inequality and lower education and early
life biological embedding get under the
skin and can influence the brain and so
then finally we come down to this whole
issue of toxic stress and early life
abuse and neglect and we of course will
hear more shortly about genes
environment about epigenetics reactive
alleles and epigenetic modifications
everyone is aware of the certainly of
many of the consequences of this chaos
in the home leading to in children
elevated levels of obesity hypertension
systemic inflammation risky families
lacking at
quit so emotional support many of the
same consequences lack of verbal
stimulation of course the famous book
meaningful differences in how vocabulary
and academic achievement diverge
depending on early-life stimulation and
then the famous studies of the
middle-class population in California
called the ace study or the adverse
childhood experiences study where the
consequences with the rising ace score
included heart disease smoking obesity
drug abuse high risk for AIDS depression
anxiety disorders anger control problems
and antisocial behavior so we know that
it has devastating lifelong influences
and then as I said we're going to hear
more about epigenetics which includes
more than just modification of histones
methylation of cytosine residues in DNA
regulation of transcription and these
micro RNAs that are very complicated and
interesting and and then we come back to
the hope for the future which is really
that this aspect of brain plasticity the
ability to reawaken a windows of
plasticity and and make them work for us
using perhaps a even a drug or some kind
of intervention like regular exercise
that opens windows and then driving it
in the direction we want with a top-down
behavioral intervention of some kind a
lot of people to thank from my own
laboratory and collaborators and the
research that we do and of course my
colleagues in the McArthur network for
socioeconomic status and health and
currently the national scientific
council for the developing child thank
you very much
you
you